[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport ganz von mir nicht
nur Hamburg steht unter Schock
Amoklauf in der Hansestadt bei der Blut
Tat in einem Gemeindehaus der Zeugen
Jehovas sterben acht Menschen der
mutmaßliche Täter war Sportschütze
die Not mit der Betreuung wie der
Personalmangel in den Kitas den
Fachkräftemangel verschärft und der
gesamten Wirtschaft schadet
und Rekord geknackt sie Königin Micaela
Schiffe gewinnt ihr 86
Weltcup-Rennen und zieht gleich mit
slalom-legende ingmarin
[Musik]
der Bundeskanzler ist fassungslos
Hamburgs Innensenator spricht vom
schlimmsten Verbrechen in der jüngeren
Geschichte der Stadt mit sieben
Todesopfern darunter ein ungeborenes
Kind und acht zum Teil schwer verletzten
gestern Abend schoss ein Amokläufer auf
die Besucher einer Veranstaltung der
Zeugen Jehovas als die Polizei kam
tötete er sich selbst die Tat ereignete
sich im Hamburger Stadtteil Alsterdorf
Spezialeinsatzkräfte der Polizei waren
in der Nähe und entsprechend schnell vor
Ort die Opferzahlen hätten sonst noch
höher sein können Martin Niesen
berichtet
im Licht des Tages zeigt sich der ganze
Horror der Nacht Bestatter
transportieren die Leichen der Getöteten
aus dem Gebetshaus der Zeugen Jehovas in
Hamburg Alsterdorf ab am Abend zuvor
hatte einen ehemaliges Mitglied der
Gemeinde zunächst mehrere Schüsse vor
dem Gebäude abgefeuert danach hat der
Täter mit der Schusswaffe durch die
Scheibe auf die Veranstaltung eingewirkt
ist im weiteren Verlauf durch das
Fenster in das Gebäude eingedrungen und
der permanenten Schusswaffengebrauch
durch Notrufe alarmiert und zufällig in
der Nähe stürmten spezialkräfte der
Polizei nur wenige Minuten später das
Gebäude für sieben Menschen kam dieser
schnelle Zugriff zwar zu spät acht
verletzt und etwa 20 weitere
Gottesdienstbesucher konnten aber in
Sicherheit gebracht werden
wirklich eine großartige Leistung der
Hamburger Polizei insbesondere auch der
besonderen Einheit der BFE die so
schnell hier vor Ort waren und dich ihr
umsichtiges Handeln und durch ihr
schnelles Handeln vielen Menschen das
Leben retten konnten im ersten Stock
stießen die Einsatzkräfte dann auf die
Leiche des mutmaßlichen Täters und die
Tatwaffe für die besaß Philipp F eine
gültige Waffenbesitzkarte erst im Januar
war der 35-Jährige von der Polizei nach
einem anonymen Hinweis überprüft worden
ein hinweisschreiben von einer bis heute
unbekannten Person mit dem Ziel dieses
Ziel ist in dem Schreiben zum Ausdruck
gebracht das Verhalten und die
waffenrechtlichen Vorschriften in Bezug
auf den Philipp F zu überprüfen eine
Überprüfung ohne größere Beanstandungen
nach der Tat stellte die
Staatsanwaltschaft in seiner Wohnung
dann mehrere hundert Schuss Munition
sicher als Motiv vermuten die Ermittler
private Gründe bei Phillip handelt es
sich um ein ehemaliges Mitglied dieser
Gemeinde der Zeugen Jehovas welches die
Gemeinde vor etwa anderthalb Jahren
freiwillig aber offenbar nicht im guten
verlassen hat viele Menschen zünden
heute Kerzen Anliegen Blumen ab am Ort
der Blut hat das Entsetzen darüber aber
geht weit über Hamburg hinaus
vor Ort in Hamburg ist Ralf Zimmermann
von sieferdrive wir haben das eben
gehört es gab im Januar einen anonymen
Hinweis auf den Täter warum blieb der
ohne Folgen
ja das Fatale an der ganzen Sache ist ja
das dieser Täter erst drei Monate eine
Waffe und auch ein Waffenschein hatte
und trotzdem die Polizei dann keine
rechtliche oder die Aufsichtsbehörde nur
die waffenrechtliche Seite prüfen konnte
aber eben nicht die Anschuldigung dass
es hier auch um psychische Labilität
womöglich ging ähm das hat heute der
Hamburger Polizeipräsident auch mal
betont dass das eben gar nicht möglich
ist das zu prüfen natürlich schon gar
nicht aufgrund eines anonym Hinweises
Hamburgs in den Senator hat jetzt
gefordert an die rote hat heute
gefordert man müsste doch oder soll weil
dringend darüber nachdenken ob ähm Leute
die einen Waffenschein beantragen schon
bei der Beantragung ihre psychische
Stabilität nachweisen müssen das ist
eine Sache die jetzt eventuell dann
Eingang findet in eine neue
Bundesgesetzgebung die sowieso im Moment
in Berlin
zusammengezimmert wird
der Mann hat auch acht Menschen zum Teil
schwer verletzt wie geht es den
zum Teil sehr sehr schlecht
der Täter ist ja mit einer automatischen
Waffe in das Gebäude eingedrungen und
hat wirklich wild um sich geschossen die
Verletzten auch die Toten natürlich
haben ganz schlimme Schutzverletzungen
die jetzt in Hamburger Kliniken versorgt
werden und die der Senat der erste
Bürgermeister Hamburgs hat jetzt den
opferschutzbeauftragten der Stadt vor
allem gebeten sich um diese Opfer zu
kümmern da wird es sicher ganz großes
Leiden geben und man muss sehen wie die
Familien wie die Angehörigen mit diesem
Leid fertig werden aber es wird
wahrscheinlich genauso schlimm sein für
die ganze Stadt heute die diesen Schock
erstmal verkraften muss vielen Dank nach
Hamburg Ralf Zimmermann von Siefert war
das
wir sind die Zeugen Jehovas was
unterscheidet sie von anderen
Religionsgemeinschaften antworten auf
diese und andere Fragen können Sie
jederzeit bei uns nachlesen in der ZDF
heute App
jetzt zur Politik am Kabinettstisch in
Berlin sollten eigentlich nächsten
Mittwoch die Eckwerte des
Bundeshaushalts 2024 beschlossen werden
Finanzminister Lindner hat den Termin
aber verschoben und auch noch keinen
neuen genannt man werde weiter über
finanzielle Realitäten sprechen müssen
sagte er gestritten wird in der Ampel
unter anderem über die
Kindergrundsicherung und mehr Geld für
die Bundeswehr auch industriehandwerk
und Unternehmen setzen die Regierung
unter Druck die Bürokratie würde uns ab
dazu kämen die weltweit höchsten Steuern
und teure Energie all das warfen die
großen Wirtschaftsverbände dem
Bundeskanzler vor die Füße bei einem
Spitzentreffen auf der Handwerksmesse in
München sie lobten zwar die
Krisenpolitik der Bundesregierung es
bestehe aber erheblicher Nachholbedarf
bitte Aumeier und Alexander Pool
berichten
ja wichtig ist dass hier drinne ist ja
sammelt sich Feuchtigkeit Heizungsbauer
chair & Sun nimmt es genau gerne würde
er mit seiner Firma für Haustechnik in
rastete näher Wärmepumpen einbauen doch
diese sind jetzt schon knapp es wird
beschlossen dass regenerative Anlagen
zum Tragen kommen sollen und auch
hauptsächlich zum Heizen des Gebäudes
eben errichtet werden sollen aber wenn
keine da sind können wir keine einbauen
trotz Lieferproblemen handwerkermeister
seines stolz auf seine Arbeit sein
Betrieb läuft und gut fürs Klima ist es
auch noch ein Grund warum Kanzler Scholz
beim Besuch der Handwerksmesse in
München dessen stand als ersten
ansteuerte beim Spitzengespräch des
Kanzlers mit den deutschen
Wirtschaftsverbänden zuvor ging es
allerdings darum was nicht so gut läuft
Deutschland muss wieder schneller werden
wir müssen einfacher werden wir müssen
wieder besser werden wir hatten ein
bisschen Glück mit einem warmen Winter
so dass das mit der
Energieversorgungssicherheit geklappt
hat aber trotzdem wir müssen auch längst
ja langen Linien also mittelfristig
Dinge jetzt in Ordnung bringen
krisenhandling alleine genügt nicht
viele sagen plagen Deutschlands
Wirtschaft hohe Energiekosten
Fachkräftemangel und zu viel Bürokratie
der Kanzler sieht Deutschland dennoch
auf einem guten Weg ich möchte sehr dass
wir diesen Schwung mitnehmen dass wir
die Dynamik des Aufbruchs selbst möglich
ist auch tatsächlich sich entfalten
lassen dass wir die Möglichkeiten für
wirtschaftliches Wachstum die vor uns
liegen nicht ungenutzt lassen die
Spitzenverbände und der Kanzler waren
sich einig vom sogenannten
deutschlandtempo der Ampelkoalition
spüren die Unternehmen bislang zu wenig
der Fachkräftemangel ist ja nicht nur
für Betriebe und die Wirtschaft ein
Problem viele bekommen ihnen längst
knallhart im Alltag zu spüren so müssen
Eltern ihre Arbeitszeit reduzieren weil
sie keine ausreichende Betreuung für
ihre Kinder haben und damit verschärft
sich dann wieder der Mangel Petra Otto
noch ein Baby so wie ihre Patientin kann
sie sich nicht erlauben schon mit einem
Kind hängt ihr Beruf am seidenen Faden
denn die Kita hat die Öffnungszeiten für
kürzt von einem Tag auf den anderen
schließt um zwei statt um 5 und wie
Ulrike darferner geht es ganz vielen
allein in unserem Praxisteam arbeiten
fünf Mütter die Kinder noch in die
Kindergartenbetreuung haben die gern
mehr arbeiten würden und könnten
tatsächlich aber nicht die Möglichkeit
haben weil die Kinder nicht betreut sind
und so dreht sich die Spirale von einer
Branche zur nächsten weil es an
Erzieherinnen fehlt und sie alle hier
nur Teilzeit arbeiten braucht die Praxis
dringend neues Personal das finden Sie
aber nicht wegen der schlechten
Kinderbetreuung eine zunehmend
bedrohliche Situation für die ganze
Volkswirtschaft experten warnen von
dieser fachkräftemangelage in den Kitas
auch schon seit vielen Jahren denn er
wirkt unmittelbar verstärkend in den
anderen Bereichen wenn Betriebe dort
ihre Beschäftigten nicht mehr so
einsetzen können weil die einfach nach
Hause müssen um ihre Kinder zu betreuen
dann bedeutet das unmittelbar auch dort
einen wachsenden Fachkräftemangel damit
er die Arbeit reduzieren als Väter
verschlechtert sich die Lage besonders
in Frauen dominierten Berufen in der
Pflege z.B Ulrike darf ferner würde
jetzt eigentlich gerne noch behandeln
muss aber ihre Tochter abholen 14 Uhr
die Arbeit im Kindergarten scheint nicht
mehr attraktiv
100.000 Stellen bundesweit offen eine
Misere schon jetzt das ist nicht die
schultererzieher da prallt ganz einfach
Personalmangel auf Personalmangel und
die Leidtragenden sind irgendwann alle
die Wirtschaft ankurbeln und die
Energiewende vorantreiben das wollen die
EU und die USA die US-Regierung hat aber
einen milliardenschweren Plan und der
heißt
inflationsreduzierungsgesetz danach
sollen Subventionen in Höhe von 370
Milliarden Dollar in Klimaschutz und
Energiesicherheit gepumpt werden
allerdings unterstreckten made in
Amerika Auflagen zu aggressiv findet die
EU und fürchtet Wettbewerbsnachteile
alte Batterien Bergen Rohstoffe für neue
das Know-how haben sie in hohbogen bei
Antwerpen sie produzieren in Europa
investieren in Nordamerika und spüren
hier wie dort die Wirkung von
subventions-
die EU hatte bis Mitte letzten Jahres
eine ganz klare Vorreiterposition im
Bereich Elektrifizierung der Green Deal
war in vollem Schwung und was wir alle
erlebt haben wir auch als als aktiver
Teilnehmer in diesem Markt mit der
letzten Jahres als die USA ihre
Inflation reduction Act veröffentlicht
hat hat sich sehr viel in Richtung USA
orientiert mit seiner Unterschrift
wollte US-Präsident Joe Biden die
US-Wirtschaft entrosten etwa E-Auto
Fabriken anziehen made in America ist
förderbedingung die eu-handelsminister
sehen darin einen Wettbewerbsnachteil
für Europa
diese massiven Subventionen für
Unternehmen in den Vereinigten Staaten
benachteiligen unsere Unternehmen in
einer Stunde ist die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin im Weißen Haus
mit Hoffnung auf einen subventionsdeckel
und weitere Schlupflöcher wie dieses
E-Autos aus Europa die ins Leasing gehen
erhalten bereits doch eine
us-kauf-prämie
jetzt sind die Rohstoffe des nächste
Thema dort haben wir auch als Europäer
ein eigenes Interesse daran uns hier
widerstandsfähigere Lieferketten
aufzubauen das ist unabhängig von den
USA aber trifft natürlich auch das
Interesse der Amerikaner denn die wollen
nie verketten ohne China Know-how wie in
Antwerpen könnte also Türöffner sein zu
einem rohstoff-club der Demokraten
im Streit um die israelische
Justizreform hat Präsident Herzog die
rechtsreligiöse Regierung um
ministerpräsident Netanjahu aufgefordert
das Projekt zu stoppen der Gesetzentwurf
unter Grabe demokratische Grundlagen
sagte Herzog seit Monaten protestieren
zehntausende gegen die Pläne dass das
Parlament Entscheidungen des höchsten
Gerichts aufheben kann und das mit
einfacher Mehrheit
seit langem sind Saudi-Arabien und Iran
Erzrivalen aber das ändert sich jetzt
möglicherweise zumindest wollen beide
Länder wieder diplomatische Beziehungen
aufnehmen in Zeit hatten sie sich nicht
nur in Glaubensfragen sondern auch im
Kampf um geopolitischen Einfluss im
Nahen Osten 2016 istkalierte der
Konflikt saudi-Arabien hatte einen
schiitischen Geistlichen hingerichtet
iranische Demonstranten griffen
daraufhin die saudische Botschaft in
Teheran an ab da lagen die Beziehungen
auf Eis der Konflikt wird auch in
Stellvertreter Kriegen in Syrien und im
Jemen ausgetragen
fragen wir unseren Experten in der
Region Jörg Brase wie ist diese
Annäherung einzuschätzen
nun zunächst mal denke ich ist das
natürlich ein großer diplomatischer
Erfolg und auch ein Beispiel für die
wachsende Bedeutung und die Rolle Chinas
in der Region beide Länder Saudi-Arabien
und Iran hatten ja in letzter Zeit
versucht ihre Beziehungen zu Peking zu
stärken nun also wollen sie ein
gesprächskanal wieder öffnen denn es ja
früher bereits schon mal gegeben hat
aber an der grundsätzlichen Rivalität
dieser beiden regionalen Mächte hat sich
erstmal nichts geändert die Rivalität
zwischen dem schiitischen Iran auf der
einen Seite und dem sunnitischen Saudi
Arabien auf der anderen Seite
Saudi-Arabien wird sicher weiter
versuchen auch eine Allianz gegen Iran
zu schmieden mit den USA mit Israel um
eben eine atomare Bewaffnung Irans zu
verhindern und auch um den wachsenden
Einfluss herans in der Region
zurückzudrängen ob nun die
Wiedereröffnung der Botschaften dazu
führen könnte das ist zum Beispiel eine
Entspannung geht auch in einem
regionalen Stellvertreter Krieg im
Jänner das muss man sehen das ist noch
zu früh das zu beurteilen aber es bleibt
natürlich zu hoffen und dafür ist es
immer besser wenn man miteinander redet
als wenn man das nicht tut absolut danke
schön für diese Einschätzung
in China hat der Nationale Volkskongress
das getan was zu erwarten war er hat
Staats- und Parteichef hiering für eine
dritte Amtszeit als Staatspräsident
bestätigt dass eine dritte Amtszeit
überhaupt möglich ist dafür hatte ich
sie selbst die Weichen gestellt ein Mann
mit enormer Machtfülle aber vor
schwierigen Aufgaben Elisabeth Schmidt
und Miriam Steimer berichten
er ist und bleibt Chinas unangefochtene
Alleinherrscher hi jimping keiner außer
Staatsgründer mau zu dunkel war bislang
so lange an der Macht wie er
ich schwöre der Verfassung der
Volksrepublik China treu zu sein
ihre Autorität aufrecht zu erhalten und
die gesetzlichen Pflichten zu erfüllen
minutenlange Applaus die Hand verlesenen
knapp 3000 Delegierten zementieren hieß
macht einstimmig für weitere 5 Jahre ein
reinformeller Akt auf den Wahlzetteln
steht ein einziger Name Hähnchen
Unterschied in pink hat die Regierung
hat der Staatsapparat ganz klar an
Bedeutung verloren beziehungsweise ist
eigentlich zunehmend von den
parteiinstitutionen eingehegt worden der
Ton in Peking wird rauer immer häufiger
Wetter Kiel gegen die USA innenpolitisch
steht er unter Druck
unsere Wirtschaft ist schwach nach drei
Jahren Pandemie ich hoffe dass es jetzt
bergauf geht nachdem die
nullcovic-politik aufgehoben wurde
ich hoffe dass unser Land immer
mächtiger wird macht bedeutet fürchi
Kontrolle
Ämter werden weiter zentralisiert ein
nationales datenbüro überwacht künftig
alle Internetaktivitäten die Meinung
geben in China die Partei und die
jimping vor
die extreme 0,- die unvorbereitete
Öffnung die gerade viele ältere mit
ihrem Leben bezahlt haben nichts deutet
darauf hin dass davon etwas
schießposition schwächt doch jetzt muss
er Vertrauen zurückgewinnen von
Unternehmen Investoren und vom eigenen
Volk
nach Frankreich dort ist heute der
britische Premier sunak zu Gast auch um
über geflüchtete zu reden ein
Dauerstreit zwischen Frankreich und
Großbritannien denn die Zahl der
unerwünschten Flüchtlinge am Ärmelkanal
nimmt stark zu im vergangenen Jahr
brachen dort fast 45.000 Menschen nach
England auf im Jahr zuvor waren es rund
30.000 mit drastischen Maßnahmen will
London jetzt die Bootsflüchtlinge
abschrecken
ein Flüchtlingscamp bei Calais an der
französischen Küste des Ärmelkanals
schon seit dem Sommer versucht Salah in
einem Boot nach England zu kommen
ich gehe jetzt für eine Stück Königreich
das ist mein Ziel kein Problem selbst
wenn ich dort ins Gefängnis muss wenn
ich nur in England sein kann
Inhaftierung gut möglich nach dem neuen
britischen Asylgesetz 28 Tage für die
die mit dem Boot ankommen Asyl bleibt
ihnen verwehrt stattdessen sind
Abschiebungen nach Ruanda geplant die
bisher aber an juristischen Hürden
scheiterten dieses Gesetz sagt zonak
unterstütze was der französische und der
britische Regierungschef beschlossen
haben Großbritannien wird eine halbe
Milliarde Euro in den kommenden drei
Jahren an Frankreich Zahlen es wird ein
neues Internierungslager in
Nordfrankreich geben und eine
Kommandozentrale von der Einsatzkräfte
zum ersten Mal gemeinsam gesteuert
werden und weitere 500 Polizisten an den
französischen Küsten
über den Kanal kamen im vergangenen Jahr
45.000 die meisten aus Albanien ob das
harte Asylgesetz der Briten mit der
Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention
vereinbar ist das ist umstritten und
Flüchtlinge einfach nach Frankreich
zurück zu schicken nein sagt macron das
könne Großbritannien nur mit der EU
besprechen
und die EU und nicht nur Frankreich und
Großbritannien müssen zusammenarbeiten
um die Schlepper effektiver zu stoppen
ein Tag voll mit freundschaftlichen
Gesten seit dem brexit waren die ganz
selten geworden
es ist eine Entscheidung gegen den
Willen des Vatikan künftig darf es in
Deutschland in der katholischen Kirche
offiziell Segens Feiern für homosexuelle
Paare geben das hat heute das
Reformprojekt synodaler Weg mit einer
Mehrheit von knapp 93% beschlossen der
Umgang mit Homosexuellen ist ein großes
Streit Thema in der katholischen Kirche
der Vatikan hatte 2021 klargestellt dass
es nicht erlaubt sei homosexuelle
Partnerschaften zu segnen in Deutschland
war es bislang ein Bereich
und jetzt Ski Alpin großer Tag für US
Superstar Michaela shiffrin sie hat
wieder einen neuen Rekord aufgestellt ja
die erfolgreichste Skirennläuferin der
Geschichte ist sie ja schon durch den 83
Weltcup Siegen Ende Januar heute im
schwerischen Ohre ihr 86 Erfolg ja und
damit hat sie den Rekord des legendären
irgendwas den Mark von 1989 eingestellt
für Michaela shiffrin schließt sich der
Kreis im schwedischen Ohre feierte sie
2012 ihren ersten Weltcup Sieg nun steht
sie an gleicher Stelle zum 86 mal ganz
oben auf dem Podium die 34 Jahre alte
Bestmarke des Schwedens den Markt
eingestellt
[Applaus]
ich werde jetzt in einem Atemzug mit ihm
genannt was die Anzahl der Siege angeht
aber sein Leistungsniveau das werde ich
glaube ich nie erreichen
sehr bescheiden die US-Amerikanerin die
beim Riesenslalom nach zwei Läufen mit
0,64 Sekunden Vorsprung auf die
zweitplatzierte Italienerin Federica
prinone ins Ziel kommt gleich bedeutend
mit dem Gewinn des Riesenslalom Weltcups
am Montag wird die zweifache
Olympiasiegerin 28 Jahre alt noch genug
Zeit um weitere Rekorde zu brechen
zur Fußball Europa League 1 2 0 Sieg für
Leverkusen gestern Abend gegen ferences
Budapest top Ausgangsposition fürs
Achtelfinale Rückspiel und auch Union
Berlin nach dem 3:38
Uhr Freiburg dagegen kassierte eine
knappe nur 21 Niederlage bei Juventus
Turin durch den Treffer von die Maria in
der 53 Minute der anschließende
vermeintliche Ausgleichstreffer durch
Lukas Höller wurde wegen eines
Handspiels von Matthias Günther
zurückgenommen nächsten Donnerstag die
Rückspiele
[Applaus]
ja eine deutlich deftigere Niederlage
dagegen für die deutschen Handballer im
ersten Länderspiel nach der WM da bekam
das Team von Alfred Gießler Sohn ganz in
Schwarz gestern Abend in alborg im
Testspiel gegen Dänemark ja eine wahre
Lehrstunde von Weltmeister 30 zu 23 hieß
es am Ende für die souveränen Gastgeber
und da musste auch noch Deutschlands
bester Werfer Juri Knorr verletzt das
fällt verlassen aber offenbar nicht
schlimmes am Sonntag ist er wohl dabei
14:15 Uhr das Spiel das Rückspiel in
Hamburg live bei uns im ZDF
ich habe fertig genau wunderbares
Stichwort für ein Jubiläum der ganz
besonderen Art sind Sie bereit
vor genau 25 Jahren bereicherte
Bayern-Trainer Giovanni Trapattoni die
deutsche Sprache um einige neue kostbar
kein Trainerin
war nicht wahr wie eine Flasche leer was
3 Minuten dauerte trapattonis Abrechnung
mit den damaligen Bayern-Stars und sie
endete mit einem heute schon Geflügel
immer wieder großartig das Wetter
weniger heute Nacht wird es stürmisch
mit kräftigem Schneefall die Details hat
gleich Christa orpen um 22 Uhr begrüßt
Sie Christian Sievers im heute-journal
wir danken für Ihr Interesse und
wünschen Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht zieht Sturmtief
Diethelm über uns hinweg nach Osten
verlagert sich mit Sturmböen im Süden
und in der Mitte im Bergland Orkanböen
bis morgen früh lässt der Wind von
Westen her dann langsam nach dreht aber
auf nördliche Richtungen das bedeutet es
wird kühler es geht also jetzt der Regen
von Norden und von Westen her immer mehr
in Schnee über das ganze verlagert sich
ostwärts nachts und in einem Streifen
von Nordrhein-Westfalen bis nach
Brandenburg da schneit es kräftig Teil
10 cm bis ins Flachland in den
Mittelgebirgen bis 15 cm und
Schneeverwehungen dazu wird es auch
richtig glatt heute Nacht vor allem im
Nordwesten da sind die Temperaturen auf
-4 Grad frostfrei bleibt es nur am
Oberrhein morgen gibt es dann den
letzten Rest Schnee im Osten das ist
aber nicht mehr viel nur im Alpenrand
bleibt das etwas mehr nachmittags ist es
dann abgezogen in den Norden zieht eine
schauerlinge mit etwas Regen Schnee und
kraupel sonst ist das morgen ein Tag zum
Durchatmen meist trocken und es gibt
auch größere sonnenanteile die
Temperaturen gleichen sich jetzt an die
Luftmassengrenze baut sich ab es gibt
ein Grad im östlichen Bergland und
sieben Grad am Rhein ja und am Sonntag
zieht von West nach Ost neuer Schnee und
neuer Regen am Montag reicht uns ein
Sturm tief mit viel Regen und einem
kurzen Frühlingstag bis 20 Grad im
Südwesten am Dienstag schon wieder
kühler Regen ist und Wind ist mit dabei
also es bleibt dabei viel los beim
Wetter tschüss